Joe Biden is about to get a supreme
check on his power the Supreme Court
hearing arguments all day in two cases
challenging the president's student loan
handout program Biden thought he could
act like a king by wiping out half a
trillion dollars of debt and make you
the taxpayer pay for it but not so fast
a coalition of Six gop-led States are
fighting back and now the top Court will
decide if Joe overstepped his authority
Chuck Schumer and the squad bashing the
conservative justices and demanding they
won't side with Biden
ninety percent of the relief going to
out-of-school borrowers will go to those
earning less than seventy five thousand
dollars a year
this isn't a handout to the wealthy
Palace and Spa
Republican
gifted from the hardship of everyday
folks
who are burdened by this debt they want
this radicalized extremist Supreme Court
to take away the hope that the president
of the United States has given those of
us who have been rallying for this cause
this unhinged Supreme Court can make all
these decisions but we're not going
anywhere the president of the United
States I hope it can hear me does have
the legal authority to cancel debt
but it's going to be an uphill battle
Biden's legal argument is drawing some
skepticism from the Chief Justice
I think most casual observers would say
if you're going to give up that much
amount of money if you're going to
affect the obligations of that many
Americans on a subject that's of great
controversy they would think that's
something for Congress to act on
the Biden Administration claims the
student debt giveaway is no different
than the government bailing out
businesses during the pandemic and a
teacher's happy Union boss agrees
join the
processes were hurting and we help them
and it didn't go to the Supreme Court to
challenge it all of a sudden when it's
about our students
they challenge it the corporations
challenge it the student loan lenders
challenge it that is not right that is
not fair
okay Greg are your ears okay why is how
can you be a liberal when everybody that
represents you screams so loudly we just
saw four people screaming well as if as
if they were faced with the apocalypse
because other people don't want to hand
over their money to them and somehow
it's the end of the world because we
refuse to hand over our money for
nothing and it appears that the Supreme
Court Chief Justice John Roberts in his
in this sound that we got earlier
comparing two students who graduate from
high school one gets a loan to go to
college the other gets a loan to buy
equipment for his Lawn Company and the
the the the Justice Roberts Robert says
it's basically a question of fairness is
that what this is all about well it's
definitely they call it debt relief but
it's more like a death depth debt
penalty the fact that they they're
whenever they say debt relief you have
to correct them because it's actually
being paid for by somebody else the
reason why we're having this problem is
because tuition skyrocketed and why did
it Skyrocket because debt was so easy in
the first place right schools jacked up
the tuition because the banks were
handing out High interest loans like
they were fentanyl in a drug Den they
created this debt spiral and now their
idea is to make it worse by handing out
more and more free money which is only
going to make the tuitions higher this
is the what I would like to see is Biden
actually explain the two like just the
normal person not a progressive why this
is go go to a blue collar middle class
the guy who owns The Lawn Company and
explain to that person who never took
anybody else's money who either paid off
his kids loans or his he paid off his
loans and tell them why he has to pay
for other people's kids who are better
off than his kids are why does he have
to do that that and he can't and if this
if and if they lose there has to be a
class action suit where every kid
or as an adult gets to sue to get their
money back the people who paid their
tuitions because it's not the taxpayer's
fault it's the banks and the schools I'm
for total I'm for this I'm for debt I'm
for debt relief if the banks and the
schools pay for it we bailed out the
banks why are they getting out of this
make them pay they're the one with the
high interest loans right that's right
turning into a communist yes you are
it's good to know and you know what
Jesse the amazing part of this is that
this case itself is a huge test of
presidential Powers this case forever
changes presidential Powers if the uh if
the court rules in Biden's favor favor
and the executive branch of the the
overreach is the fundamental issue here
you know Biden if you remember before
the before the midterms he basically
said you know the checks are in the mail
well I'm not a constitutional scholar
but it's illegal to bribe it's really
illegal when the president does it to
get reelected
so the Democrats want credit for not
fixing a problem that they created
so let me get this straight the
Democrats push millions of Americans
into debt and then say you know what
we're going to comp about five percent
of it
they want credit for that and then
Republicans are supposed to be mean
because under the Constitution bribery
is illegal that's basically what's going
on the politicians are in cahoots with
the universities they jack up debt they
put you in a 200 000 debt dungeon they
give you a worthless degree and they
teach you that America's racist so you
get out of college you think
everything's racist so Joe says here's a
check for 10 grand
and the Republicans say you can't do
that and they want you to be mad at the
Republicans they want you to be mad at
the racist court that says bribery is
illegal and say now This Racist Court
needs to be packed and you better vote
for me again and the fact that they have
the nerve judge to say that the
Republican party isn't really in touch
with the working class men and women of
this country this is a Democratic party
that hasn't even visited East Palestine
yeah that hollowed out these Rust Belt
towns they it doesn't go to the Border
towns that that wanted to fire Frontline
essential workers for not getting vaxxed
you know who's jacking up Energy prices
jacking up food prices and we're
supposed to feel sorry for a person that
got a graduate degree that is renting a
studio apartment in Georgetown and is
still single we're supposed to feel
sorry for a depressed single person with
a graduate degree who lives in Boston
why am I feeling sorry for that why are
they the Forgotten men and women who
just describe the MSNBC viewer
why are we bailing out these people he's
the last people we should be bailing out
and it is hard to run against free money
because that's the challenge that is
what can you do when you're running
against free money all right Dana it
sounds like when you've got the likes of
ill Hannah Omar and Rashida Talib and
even Elizabeth Warren and you know
everybody's saying this is legal the
president has the right to do this uh
and already they're starting starting to
attack the institution of the Supreme
Court it sounds like a run-up to the
Dobbs decision where they're almost
predicting what it's going to be and uh
they they're basically saying uh that
that we know it's legal and questioning
the credibility of the Supreme Court
perfect question for me okay so the the
the women you saw yelling so
vociferously the reason Joe Biden is in
this position is one he made a terrible
decision but it's because the squad
pushed him into it if you go back and
you see Joe Biden on the campaign Trail
and in his first year in office and then
also backed up by Speaker Pelosi they
were telling the squad
the president of the United States
doesn't have the legal authority to do
this we understand what you're saying we
agree that it's a problem but they don't
have the legal authority to do that only
Congress could do that but what happens
they get they get pushed back from the
left Ron Clayton the chief of staff at
the White House doesn't tell them to sit
down he says maybe we gotta accommodate
them and they want to bribe the younger
voters before the midterm elections so
they said okay we're going to do it the
Supreme Court says uh not so fast we
think this is illegal so we're going to
have to to have a listen to it so what
the justices were saying today was
exactly what Biden and Pelosi said at
the beginning so yeah I'm glad that the
squad went there because they are the
ones that put them there in the first
place do you see Abigail spamberger
there no were there any demons were
there any moderate Democrats there no
moderate Democrats are there because
they know it's illegal but this is the
play judge this is what they always do
so the Democrats will exceed their power
okay and then they'll dare somebody to
sue them for it they know that it's
illegal but they exceed the power they
dare you to sue them you sue them and
you win and then it's the court that's
racist it's the court that's wrong it's
an institution that's bad and then
they're worried about con people not
having any faith in the institutions
what it but how Herald the issue is even
if they win the question is is it on the
merits or is it procedural so let's talk
about the fact that Amy Coney Barrett
and I think you and I have visited this
in the past Amy Conant Barrett uh would
not halt the student loan uh forgiveness
because the individuals who sued the
plaintiffs did not have standing so now
the issue is do the people before The
Supreme Court have standing can the
Supreme Court make a decision and then
the White House says gee we won because
they didn't have standing when they know
they don't win this case is different
they they now have said this is a few
States several States and a few
individuals look even when we had that
difference of opinion outside I didn't I
didn't I never believed that this case
was not a strong case you still have to
have standing to bring them out or you
and I can't bring certain matters
against certain certain people and vice
versa but let me agree with you
um this is not a run-up to Dobbs for
this reason Dobbs there was precedent
already for 50 years the president here
is
accident is the heroes act can I just
the president no they're wrong you know
why because the heroes Act was voted on
by Congress that when President Bush I
criticized President Bush yesterday
around and really a favorable Way by
saying look he thought what was right he
thought he was right in doing what he
did with the Iraq War and turned out
wrong and President Bush had to send
secretary Paulson and chairman Beneke
before the Congress to urge them to vote
for the bill that Greg mentioned uh the
legislation that provided money for the
banks so the economy would not go under
they did not pass that vote the first
time the market dropped 900 points that
day and the next day they finally passed
it even the coveted relief that Miss
Weingarten was speaking of when she was
the clip we showed of her Congress voted
on that so if we believe and I happen to
believe not giving everyone uh student
debt relief we've talked about in the
show we ought to give summerly to those
professions where we really need help I
believe in National strategic
Investments what we're doing with the
semiconductor chip Act is akin to that
why not provide relief to engine years
including mechanics and plumbers why not
provide relief to teachers and nurses in
emergency physicians where we need that
we need more people doing that's where
the investment ought to be but even if
you do that judge you still have to go
back before the Congress I would caution
some of my Democratic friends I share
your view that there should be some
relief for those for students who are
faced with crushing burdens but this is
not the way to do it this is a
congressional matter Congress cannot be
run around we're going to have a moment
where there's going to be a Republican
president who's going to do something we
don't like and we're going to yell and
we're going to scream do it the right
way make the case in perhaps the country
I think we can convince a big part of
the country to come along and give
nurses and emergency physicians and
mechanics and plumbers and other
Engineers a break on their tuition
do you know how many zeros there are in
400 trillion the 40 trillion I think is
what you meant but 400 trillion be one
zero more than the 40.
I counted them hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now